[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale avec tv
60,18 bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal tout
de suite les titres de ce lundi à 26
novembre les habitants de coignières
étaient appelés aux urnes hier pour une
élection municipale partielle la liste
sans étiquette nouvel élan pour
coignières de didier fischer arrive en
tête à l'issue du premier tour
ali bruxelles à mes deuxièmes david
pelletier dernier réaction à suivre dans
cette édition c'est le deuxième document
du genre pour trappe avec l'état et
l'éducation nationale la ville a signé
samedi son projet éducatif de territoire
il organise toute la politique éducative
trappistes au travers d'actions menées
auprès des jeunes
une signature qui a clôturé la semaine
de l'éducation dans la commune enfin
avec noël qui approchent et le mois de
décembre qui débute ce week end vous
êtes peut être à la recherche d'un
calendrier de l'avent depuis quelques
années la mode et de le faire soi même
on vous explique tout en chronique des
invités également à suivre dans ce
journal paul martinez président de l'udf
78 qui nous parlera de la stratégie du
parti en vue des européennes de 2019 et
puis de membres du cyclotourisme de
maurepas l'association développe son
projet autour du paracyclisme c'est à
suivre dans ce journal
les jets les jaunes de nouveau mobilisés
ce week-end contre la hausse des prix du
carburant et contre la hausse également
la baisse pardon du la hausse du coût de
la vie pardon en plus de la mobilisation
à paris des rassemblements se tenait
dans les yvelines
sur ces images au péage de buchelay
l'autoroute a13 ou une opération péage
gratuit a été de nouveau mené entre une
cinquantaine une centaine de personnes
présentes samedi et dimanche délogés par
les forces de l'ordre hier matin les
manifestants ont prévu de faire des
actions jusqu'à mardi soir avant les
annonces des manuels macron sur la
transition écologique et l'ambiance
était bon enfant au péage de saint
arnoult en yvelines sur l'a10 avec une
opération également péage gratuit au
rythme de la macarena élections donc ce
dimanche à coignières après la démission
du maire sur fond de tensions au sein de
la majorité les électeurs étaient
appelés aux urnes avec une participation
de 47% celle opposant sans étiquette qui
arrive en tête devant
et les deux listes de l'ancienne
majorité elle aussi non renvendiqué
aucune appartenance politique les
précisions avec ce sujet de wilfrid
richy les images de marylène yapi chinon
là didier fischer est accrue c'est dès
le premier tour qu'ils auraient pu
l'emporter à 24 voix près un second tour
sera nécessaire dimanche de décembre
afin de désigner le nouveau maire de
coignières il totalise 48,03 % des
suffrages exprimés contre 36,30 % pour
ali bousselham et 15,59 % pour david
pelletier un électeur sur deux s'est
déplacé aux urnes
donc j'appelle moi vraiment les poignées
rien à se mobiliser dimanche parce que
il ya effectivement je dirais encore
encore à travailler
et voilà il faut donner un nouvel élan à
coignières didier fischer ancien
adhérent du parti socialiste déjà
candidat aux derniers scrutins est
aujourd'hui sans étiquette pourrait donc
faire basculer la commune ces deux
opposants aussi un membre de la majorité
de jean pierre sevestre dorénavant
opposé ne peuvent que constater les
conséquences de cette division sur
l'opinion des toits n'y a rien je
regrette que les quads mais rien ne soit
pas venu beaucoup plus nombreux pour
s'exprimer puis évidemment choisir
le plus possible par le mieux possible
en tout cas leur mère donc j'espère je
les invite encore une fois à venir
nombreux ce type 2
d'élection n'a de sens vraiment que si
la population se déplace en masse parce
que c'est important c'est vraiment la
vie quotidienne de déco aérien avec tous
les dangers que nous avons évité
depuis donc je reste rempli d'espoir si
la fusion était était une erreur il faut
le reconnaître
la tentative de fusion en tout cas
aujourd'hui
elle doit quand même vivre dans son
environnement et son environnement c'est
saint quentin en yvelines
donc je trouve que ce score il est même
si forcément il est un petit peu
décevant pour nous il est quand même
honorable
parce que on n'est pas des pros de la
politique leur de liste pourrait se
maintenir david pelletier n'avait encore
pris aucune décision lundi soir mais
imaginez ma l'idée d'une fusion
politique toujours avec mon premier
invité paul martinez bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de la fédération
udi des yvelines également maire de buch
là on parle avec vous des élections
européennes et de la stratégie en vue de
cette élection juste avant une réaction
sur cette actualité le président de
l'union des maires ruraux des yvelines
maire de méricourt philippe g cement a
été condamné à trois ans d'inéligibilité
par le conseil constitutionnel il était
la tête de liste du modem aux dernières
sénatoriales
et c'est d'ailleurs pour son retard dans
le dépôt de son compte de campagne lors
de ces sénatoriales qu'il a été condamné
quelle est votre réaction j'ai pas de
réaction particulière c'est une
négligence effectivement matériel qui
coûte très cher monsieur ghislain
malheureusement c'est quand même dommage
parce que c'est un maire d'une grande
qualité et beaucoup de maires ruraux
le penseur je pense alors l'union des
démocrates et indépendants a présenté à
versailles vendredi et sa stratégie pour
les élections européennes au programme
le 26 mai 2019 avant d'en parler quels
sont les enjeux
selon vous pour pour ces élections est
ce que c'est plus un vote sanction pour
ceux qui ne seraient pas satisfaits de
la politique d' emmanuel macron il ya de
réels enjeux derrière cette élection
comment votre présenté il ya deux
raisons je ceux qui veulent faire de
cette élection un maquereau batchingou
un référendum contre contre hénin de
macron veulent amener le peuple français
encore sur des thématiques
populis caricatural le but n'est pas là
cette élection au fondamental dans la
mesure où il peut sortir du scrutin du
mois de mai prochain
une majorité populiste au sein du
parlement européen du jamais vu une
majorité qu'on pourrait qualifier de
l'euro destructeur donc bien évidemment
élevé mauvaise nouvelle bien évidemment
lui dei qui est parmi les familles poli
de la famille politique c'est pas parmi
ces la famille politique dont l'adn est
le plus européen nous sommes m
fédéraliste d'antan plein plein sens du
terme
nous considérons qu effectivement une
telle majorité au parlement européen ce
serait absolument une catastrophe dans
la mesure où le projet rotin serez
complètement avoir été disons le comment
sensibiliser aujourd'hui les français
qui sont peu nombreux à chaque fois se
mobiliser pour ces élections européennes
-2 43% lors des élections européennes de
on leur dit par exemple que les
thématiques qui doivent être gérés à
l'échelle du continent européen
sont celles de leur quotidien aussi
c'est pas simplement cette europe qui
existe qui est souvent caricaturée
technocratique qui s'occupe de telle ou
telle norme c'est aussi ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui par exemple avec la révolte
et gilet jaune
cette question de la fiscalité
écologique
cette question delà de la lutte contre
le changement climatique
elle ne peut pas s'opérer et ils ont
raison quelque part aussi des gilets
jaunes de le dire qu'à l'échelle de la
france il faut que ce serait coordonnée
à l'échelle européen et ça c'est une des
politiques publiques on veut mener nous
lui dit à l'échelle du continent bien
sûr lors du dernier scrutin justement en
2014 lui d y était parti avec le modem
vous aviez récoltés dans les yvelines
14% vous classant notamment devant le ps
las pour ces élections ça va être quoi
la stratégie refaire une alliance partir
seul l'élu de l'essonne par exemple
appel à partir seul pour cette campagne
quelle est la position votre position
sur le sujet lui dei de l'essonne et
beaucoup d'autres fédérations appellent
a effectivement à partir seul dans la
mesure où effectivement la majorité
plutôt européenne du président macron et
ses alliés du modem qui étaient les
nôtres vous avez raison de le rappeler
il ya quelques années dans la mesure où
ils se retrouvent un peu coincé dans les
débats nationaux que l'on connaît
nous on veut préserver la question
européenne et les questions européennes
d'une manière générale et il nous faut
présenter un projet européen à plein
bien sûr donc partir seul serait une
solution
nos alliés d'antan les ait l'air ayant
tout une toute autre vocation
aujourd'hui en matière d'europe c'est
pas tout à fait ceux avec qui on compte
effectivement scellier donc partir seul
peut être une solution parce que nous
avons en projet une identité très
particulière autour du fédéralisme cette
europe puissance en quelque sorte avec
qui vous étiez parti notamment lors des
présidentielles et des législatives en
2017 du coup quand ça va se décider
c'est lors du congrès national le 15
décembre que tout ça va se décider c'est
ce congrès extraordinaire qui va nous
faire décider si nous partons seuls ou
avec d'autres
il semble évident que au sein dudit les
militants a fortiori après les
différentes séquences de réorganisation
des fichiers politiques les différents
militants les différents élus ont quand
même l'intention de porter cette
question de l'europe puissance qui vient
au service et en protection des
européens et des français notamment ont
envie de porter cette question
seul pour pouvoir effectivement montré
la différence que nous avons avec tous
les autres partis politiques sur cette
question
et pour terminer en 30 secondes ça est
compliqué je le sais la vision de lully
pour l'europe c'est laquelle les
priorités la priorité elle est
effectivement de lutter contre les
comment dirais-je les les problématiques
de climat ça c'est fondamental c'est
aussi donner en quelque sorte à cette
europe une capacité de faire balance
entre guillemets avec les super
puissances que sont la russie les états
unis notamment
et bien évidemment d'accompagner tous
les européens dans un quotidien autour
d'eux on a plusieurs thématiques sur la
sécurité avec la création d'un parquet
général
on a aussi les thématiques autour de
l'indépendance énergétique comme je
voulais dit l'idée c'est de rendre cet
or plus puissante et indépendante à
l'égard du reste du monde en quelque
sorte
merci paul martinez d'avoir été avec nos
présidents de la fédération u10 et des
yvelines également maire de buchelay
sorcier vous on vous parlait de ce cet
événement la semaine dernière trap
organisé sa semaine de l'éducation pour
clôturer ce rendez-vous élus
représentants de l'état et de
l'éducation nationale ont signé le
deuxième projet éducatif de territoire
de la commune reportage de nicolas
landry et de marylène iapichino la
semaine de l'éducation organisée à
trappes se termine en signature celle du
projet éducatif de territoire véritable
ossature de la politique éducative de la
ville
il permet d'impulser et de mettre en
cohérence les actions menées dans tous
les domaines éducatif culturel et
sportif des enfants et des jeunes et
donc on voit que l'intérêt est essentiel
on sait que personne ne travaille
entre deux cloisons tout le monde
travaille avec un suivi de l'enfant dans
sa personne et dans sa diversité
ça concerne ça concerne treize mille
cinq cents jeunes de la ville
c'est le deuxième projet être signé un
véritable travail de concertation entre
les équipes pédagogiques
la ville les associations et les parents
d'élèves demandent beaucoup de dialogues
beaucoup de patients mais aussi beaucoup
de rigueur pour pour rester dans le
concret quoi
rester dans le concret dans le faisable
aussi et non pas dans l'illusion
directeur de l'académie de versailles
préfet et directrice générale de la
caisse d'assurance familiale des
yvelines étaient présents pour montrer
leur soutien au projet l'éducation à
trappes cesser le coeur et ayez c'est
pour cela que nous sommes là et nous
avons voulu à la fois marquer la volonté
des services de l'état se d'éducation
nationale particulièrement de soutenir
tout cela un travail éducatif comment a
réalisé par l'ensemble des acteurs pour
les enfants et jeunes de 0 à 25 ans
c'est en ce moment la semaine du
handicap à maurepas deuxième édition de
ce rendez vous dans la ville avec
plusieurs animations notamment samedi
près de la halle du marché présentation
et démonstration de vélos adaptés
proposé par le club de cyclotourisme de
mort pas avec moi pour en parler en
plateau de membres du club jean-pierre
chardon et jean-yves pervis bonsoir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous on va
bien sûr parler de cette animation mais
aussi et surtout du projet actuel du
club de cyclotourisme de maurepas
souhaite développer le paracyclisme une
première question pour commencer
pourquoi c'est si important pour vous de
d'aller dans ce sens de développer le
paracyclisme à maurepas
l'objectif l'objectif c'est d'apporter
des solutions à des personnes qui à un
moment de leur vie rencontres soit la
maladie soit l'accident soit le handicap
et leur faire prendre conscience qu'il
ya des solutions qui existent
alors si on vient justement sur la
genèse du projet jean yves pervis soudan
est à l'origine ancien cycliste de haut
niveau et vous étiez aussi le président
du ct maurepas vous êtes atteints d'une
maladie neurodégénérative
pourquoi c'est nécessaire pour vous de
lancer ce projet pourquoi ça nous tenait
à coeur
donc après tout
mais un peu isolé comme ça bonjour a vu
de quoi étaient de l'avis du coup et on
sera un peu tout ça donc la pac man où
je vais que je serai décideurs nous vous
aider des clubs qui ont un poids paille
puis deuxièmement et bien puisque je
suis assez certain pourquoi pas en faire
partie des solutions grise c'est
intéressant a réalisé 6 novembre où vit
et est donc c'est un peu là l'adema vous
avez dit mise à l'écart c'est ce que
vous avez ressenti
oui oui mais pour vignes à beaune ses
pouvoirs en voyant tant de difficultés
par un ongle socialement à sa sécurité
un petit peu deviennent donc à bâtir là
bas il reste pas grand chose comme comme
une possibilité si je jouais aussi
fonctionne encore et qui vont encore se
sont émus c'est ici au niveau des gens
elle fonce a encore récidivé vous à
spéciaux et puis je me suis aperçu que
ça allait très bien donc là quand je
sors de mon isolement il veut les verts
bien sûr la forêt rambouillet sur
motrices
c'est une audi guérin pour abattue
là-bas j'ai ces lois qui commet il y
avait d'autres parfums g16 gens et je me
suis aperçu qu'en effet il y avait
d'autres peu un club handisport et c'est
appartient cette rencontre
j'ai eu besoin de regrouper à ce que dit
jean yves ferri ce très important il
existe des solutions il faut pas voilà
s'abattent sur ce projet sur ce sur ce
dossier pardon il existe des solutions
bien évidemment jean yves a commencé une
démarche d'ordre tout à fait personnelle
comme il l'indiquait il était atteint
d'une maladie neurodégénérative
on n'arrive pas à mettre un nom le corps
médical a rich man à mettre un nom
dessus
il a commencé par écrire et un trac un
vélo couché adapté pour pouvoir faire
d'exercice un peu seul et puis après
comme il le dit justement autour de lui
s'est aperçu qu'ils aient beaucoup de
populations qui avaient elles aussi des
quais t elle aussi dans des situations
d'un thème et qui adaptait leur statut
du moment avec des
adapter et à ce titre là il a pris il
est entre en contact avec la section
handisport de saint quentin en yvelines
avec la section dire aux loisirs
et c'est dans ces sections on trouve
différentes natures de vélos adaptés
pour maintenir une pratique saine et
aujourd'hui concrètement il disait il ya
des contacts ont été établis avec
d'autres clubs le vc sky vous en parlait
le développement de saint quentin en
yvelines j'arrive encore à nice port
chez eric el fassi qui du reste a
disparu qui ont attiré le mur a appris
et à créer un
comment une section handisport sans lien
avec la position du club et sont en
osmose
c'est exceptionnel la région parisienne
ça n'existe pas les clubs valides si
vous voulez on peut encore nourrir
il ya des dangers du soleil je serai pas
peut pas expliquer ça si elle pose le
problème j'espère d'air après il ya un
an nous un nouveau venir c'est pareil à
paris tout est d'un type c'est en ça je
m'éclaire il a créé une chambre pour une
rapide des handicapés mais c'est son
assistant
exonhit a lieu à tout le monde y compris
les gens en mal de repères et c'est à
dire des choses des choses bien se font
au niveau français ça sera le cas et
c'est le cas également arrivé c'était
mon record et c'est le comble est venu
avec ma famille d'accord est justement
pour parler cette cette journée de
samedi que vous organisez 10h à 12h 36m
matinée de présentation et et de test de
ces vélos adaptés qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir justement testé samedi
ce qu'il faut dire déjà c'est que
l'intervention du ce était mort parce
effectué dans le cas de la semaine du
handicap qui se déroulent cette semaine
donc à maurepas
avec en point d'orgue samedi matin dans
le cadre du marché de madère la
présentation et la démonstration de vélo
adapté donc chacune des sections condom
on a évoqué l'existence n'a levé c'est
sky en dire ou loisirs vont présenter
leur monture adaptée vont faire faire
des tours de
à des personnes on a en adhérant de
notre club qui a eu un grave accident de
la route qui a perdu l'usagé d'une jambe
qui va pour la première fois samedi
monté sur un vélo adapté pour voir ce
qu'il peut faire aujourd'hui avec son
handicap du moment donc l'idée c'est de
proposer de les faire tester ce site
sensibiliser j'imagine elle est morte
asia qui se voilent en présence sur le
web l'objectif c'est d'aller au delà du
périmètre des saints associations
sportives c'est sensibiliser la poule la
population sens large une dernière
question ce qui nous reste unie et
allait les ambitions pour le ct mort pas
quels sont tes actions et en mouvement
et très simplement elle paye un peu mon
intérêt pour le lkp mais je ne sais pas
où ils vont ment pas il ya une autre
section est avec nous et m
chez les incroyables de quoi ils palin
qu'elle est et non voyants et il ya
encore mieux quand même prévenu le roi
tu savais l'échappée belle ont eu
souvent ils paient pour et en voyant on
a greffé une section au niveau des
sédiments pas pour développer la seconde
en ce qu'il faut dire c'est que le
projet du site et maurepas a été
identifié comme un projet fédéral aussi
avec des dotations bien évidemment
financière de la part de la fédération
française de vélo anciennement à premier
fédération française de cyclotourisme
est sponsorisé par ag2r la mondiale qui
nous aident à promouvoir cette
initiative au sein du ct maurepas et
donc rendez vous ce samedi de 10h à
12h30 près de la halle du marché merci
jean pierre charreton merci la rive
permise d'avoir été avec nous toutes les
informations sur le site et maurepas
sont à retrouver sur sur son site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et puisqu'on parle de cyclisme messieurs
souhaitons un joyeux anniversaire à
robert marchand il fête ce lundi ses 107
ans le cycliste est le détenteur de
plusieurs records de l'heure dans sa
catégorie d'âge des exploits réalisés au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines en octobre robert marchand
était d'ailleurs revenu dans l'enceinte
pour s'entraîner malgré sa retraite
sportive et pour souffler ses bougies le
centenaire a réalisé aujourd'hui à vélo
20 km sur les routes d'ardèche
on reparlera sport dans ce journal dans
un instant mais d'abord ce sujet quant à
tim burton inspirent les chorégraphes le
réalisateur américain
et le point de départ de la nouvelle
création du de la compagnie écho inspiré
de quatre contre quatre chorégraphes ont
créé quatre solos les petites histoires
de sont à découvrir au prisme
d'elancourt le 27 novembre
mélanie poker des toges blanches et sa
peau est allé tout raccommoder et lé
plein d'épinglé ce sont les premiers
mots de la fille vaudou de tim burton
qui ont inspiré kettly noël chorégraphe
haïtienne pour la compagnie écho c'est
une fille qui danse qui rentre en
transes
mais en fait autour d'elle est elle à
des fantômes mais si ces fantômes se
rapprochent d'elle elle a des épingles
qui rend dans le coeur qui vont à la
personne donc ça c'est déjà une base
après kate qui a fait tout un travail
par rapport au voodoo évidemment en
transposant cette histoire c'est
l'inversé les petites histoires deux
sont au nombre de quatre 4 compte quatre
visions emilio calcagno le directeur
artistique voulait s'interroger sur la
jeunesse la différence c'est sûr que non
c'est librement inspirée des contes
d'une burton il ne s'agit absolument pas
de retrouver ni les dessins ni les
images de films ce qui est intéressant
c'est la narration dont ces comptes sont
des comptes qui sont très courts
elle a duré de sept de la narration
c'est à peu près la même sur le plateau
donc j'ai vraiment eu envie de créer des
capsules chorégraphique
il faut à peu près 15 minutes 4 solos le
mouvement le corps et le danseur sont au
coeur de la création
les interprètes alors tout vous confient
les petites histoires 2 et pour terminer
ce journal deux journalistes de la
rédaction m'ont rejoint en plateau
mélanie pokémon soir ça et mikel el nido
robond soir dans ça grogne commence avec
vous d'ailleurs michael avec du sport
[Musique]
comme chaque lundi vous nous donner les
derniers résultats sportifs du week end
commence par du handball direction le
championnat de pré régionale c'est ça on
joue et la 8e journée ce samedi 24
novembre et les bleu et blanc de trappes
sont imposés tout en maîtrise face au
mur au dernier du classement de cette
première régionale les trappistes
l'emportent 43 à 35 dans leur gymnase à
après un festival offensif on écoute les
réactions micro de notre journaliste
nicolas d'andré pense que les mérites et
on s'est tous donné à 200 %
on a su jouer même physiquement jusqu'au
bout malgré des trous défensif qui nous
ont fait mal
certaines périodes mais sinon dans
l'ensemble ça a été de ces travaux
l'équipe en face était redire sur le
papier - forte qui se sont renforcées
mais ça reste une équipe qui était
largement à notre portée normalement
mais une équipe que le leader a battu
que de six buts la semaine dernière donc
là on leur met sept buts
l'objectif est atteint résultat qui
pourrait être un tournant dans la saison
des trappistes cette deuxième victoire
consécutive permet aux joueurs de
frédéric bélanger de grimper à la 4e
place du championnat après huit matches
disputés la montée l'objectif du club
semble accessible le premier à deux
points devant donc une victoire étant à
trois points tout et tout est très serré
et vu qu'il ya 2 2 places pour monter en
région c'est encore tout à fait faisable
maintenant faudra faire mieux mais voilà
on est on est on est on est dans l'est
on est dans les places on est encore en
vie des trappes continuera de tentera de
continuer sa remontée à date je vais
réussir à le dire grégory dès le mois de
janvier prochain après la brève trêve
hivernale et rapide ses déplacements sur
le terrain à de belles vous aimez ça la
raie manta d'âge augmente à dahouët
c'est ma toute émoustillée on continue
toujours du handball mais mais côté
féminin cette fois-ci voilà
montigny-le-bretonneux a lourdement
chuté sur le terrain de rouen lors de la
8e journée du championnat de nationale 2
les îles montaigne se sont inclinés à 29
à 20 à l'extérieur
au classement les yvelinoises reste à la
7e place avec un bilan négatif de 3
victoires pour déjà cinq défaites
place à la trêve maintenant pour l'euro
de handball féminin le prochain match
est programmé le 12 janvier contre
lisieux
on leur souhaite de se reposer pendant
les fêtes de noël et de ne pas abuser du
forum avec modération enfin du basket
pour finir mutuelle la 8e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 masculine
trappe se déplacer sur le terrain de
vineuil et les trappistes sont repartis
avec une victoire dans leur valise ils
se sont imposés sur le fil 72 à 67 dans
un match très serré au classement trappe
reprend la deuxième place à son
adversaire du jour et revient à un petit
point de la première place détenue par
poti merci votre émission le 7-8 sport
dans un instant de quoi parlera et vous
on recevra notamment un apnéiste xavier
delpy la plongée à plus de 100 mètres de
profondeur nous recevrons également
tristan au cou et dell qui participera
au rallye automobile africa eco race et
c'est à suivre
après ce journal mais avant on va vous
écoutez quand même mélanie poquet dans
un mois dans moins d'un mois pardon
c'est noël un dernier mois qui met la
patience à rude épreuve pour attendre
plus sereinement que le père noël se
rendent mieux grande pardon donne ses
cadeaux au pied du sapin on va y arriver
rien de mieux qu'un calendrier de
l'avent mélanie depuis quelques années
la mode est au fait soi même
et oui il faut vous dire grégory qu'en
2015 il s'est vendu près de 12 millions
de calendrier une tradition qui nous
vient d'allemagne à l'époque durant 24
jours ont donné des images pieuses alors
depuis le calendrier a bien changé il ya
des chocolats des bonbons des jouets du
fromage et même des bières on peut aussi
le créer soit grégory vous l'avez dit on
peut pas varier le plaisir il ya
plusieurs sortes de calendrier ce qu'on
dit le do it yourself do it yourself
alors là aussi beaucoup de choix quand
on a un peu de temps vous pouvez faire
tout le calendrier en créant des boîtes
en cachant les surprises dans des
enveloppes ou des petites sacoches
aussi acheter des structures en bois
qu'il suffit de décorer beaucoup de
commerçants proposent même des ateliers
c'est ce que vous voyez sur les images
et pour vous dire l'engouement cette
enseigne d'activités créatives devant un
millier de modèles chaque année tous les
ans on entend énormément les maisons
pèse beaucoup le calendrier en forme de
triangle et beaucoup aussi
donc avec des décorations divers des
couleurs diverses
le calendrier peut être mis en valeur
tous les ans et puis les familles aiment
bien et préparer ensemble
alors cette enseigne à en rayon une
dizaine de modèles même nombre de
modèles dans une autre enseigne elle
situe à mon amour pas compter entre 15
et 30 euros le support de quoi faire et
se faire plaisir
il faut quand même compter deux bonnes
heures pour aller réaliser son propre
calendrier c'est donc une activité à
faire en famille est dedans qu'est ce
qu'on peut lui mettre dans ce cas tout
ce qui fera plaisir aux destinataires je
ne sais pas quels sont vos goûts grégory
mes parents je vous propose d'écouter
les principaux intéressés des kim carr
surprise les fouilles du chocolat des
chocolats pour moi c'est le chocolat
aussi en tout cas plus que quelques
jours à patienter le 1er décembre c'est
ce samedi
merci mélanie le 7-8 journal touche à sa
fin le replay ces reportages sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile belle soirée
avec télé 78
[Musique]